okay so hello and welcome to pi data
global 2021
my name is rosa and i'm glad to be here
the host of this workshop the workshop
that we have right now uh is uh about
behind the back black box and how to
understand any machine learning model
using chat library
and our speaker is jonathan becks
bechtel did i pronounce it well sir very
well yeah it's a german last name
i know yeah
actually your guttural pronunciation is
actually much better than i pronounce it
i think yeah that's perfect
and is the lead data science instructor
for general assembly which is a global
technology education company he has
delivered over 1 000 workshops and
corporate trainings to students on the
subjects of data science programming and
machine learning
and his corporate trainings have helped
companies in the private equity
consulting accounting and hedge fund
industries to incorporate analytical
tool chains and realize the power of
data driving decisions making and
business processes
so i think that was my part here
i'm going to stop sharing
thank you all right so
awesome everyone for for being here
uh you know i i see this beautiful you
know panorama of different people and
attendance here from from all across the
world
uh so it's definitely flattering to know
that we might have someone from almost
every single time zone right kind of in
this workshop here you know to learn
more about data science and model
interpretability uh so it's definitely a
privilege to have you all in attendance
so thank you very very very much for
being here
um we'll cover a little bit of errata
and then we'll just go ahead and jump in
all right so
let's kind of go ahead here uh let's get
the party started
all right i'll start my presentation
all right
and we'll go from there all right so the
workshop here uh that you're attending
it's called behind the black box uh how
to understand any ml model with shaq all
right
um so you i'm i'm going to be your
teacher here for the next two hours very
excited to do it
i definitely think we're going to have
an awesome time we're going to cover a
lot of interesting material and again
having so many people from around the
world i think is really inspiring you
know so thank you everyone for your
attendance
a little bit of background about me um
you know in terms of my you know my
official credential in life uh i have an
ms analytics from georgia tech
i work for the last 40 years
as a data science lead here at general
assembly
it is an education and consulting
company
in the tech and programming space and so
i work mostly
in their data science department which
covers you know some aspects of python
programming
machine learning and then just general
data science and so uh things are taught
both to adult students
as well as you know corporations on site
and then i also work individually uh
with companies mostly in the new york
area because that's where i'm domiciled
uh but also you know a few that are
scattered you know throughout the
country as well
and so uh the work there is also pretty
similar
you know uh kind of helping companies uh
set up their their their data systems
you know throughout their organizations
and then just build out various types of
analytical solutions and platforms you
know on top of whatever it is you're
looking to go ahead and then solve for
the company
all right so i've been doing this uh for
about the last five or six years i've
been working with data in general uh you
know for about the last ten um if you
want my official watering hole in the
internet uh to kind of understand more
about me professionally uh my website
www.jonathanbeck.com
okay uh feel free to wander over there
if you just want to get a closer look at
what i do obviously if you search for me
know you can find my linkedin profile
and then my my general assembly teacher
page things like that it's not too hard
so if you're curious uh you're only a
google search away from getting into
more detail on what's listed on the
slide
uh but that's kind of the postcard
version of me
if it were a normal workshop you know i
would expect there to be maybe 10 or 12
different people and i would have this
to introduce ourselves uh being that
they're 100 plus i don't think that's
going to be feasible so we're going to
go ahead and just kind of talk about the
agenda and then just dive right in
all right so the idea is right we're
gonna talk um about a software library
called shop
okay
and uh the big idea here
uh is the real theme behind uh this
morning's workshop morning for me
afternoon for you all
uh is we're gonna talk about uh the
general idea of model interpretability
okay
and uh kind of how for a long time
there's been a fundamental trade-off uh
between models that are very very
accurate and then models that can be
easily explained all right there's a
natural tension between these two
paradigms
and a shop i think more so than any
other solution
has really brought a lot of closure to
this trade-off and in the last two or
three years it's very quickly
established itself as i think probably
the best way uh to really understand and
explain uh non-linear black box models i
have definitely found a lot of use work
in my professional life uh because a lot
of times you know if you're trying to
actually build out an analytical
solution for a company uh getting buy-in
from various people who don't maybe
understand the models themselves is
typically very important this is usually
a pretty important bridge for that
so what we're going to do then okay
we're going to talk first
about some of the theoretical
foundations of shapley values which is
what the library is built off of so kind
of go ahead and then build some from
scratch
uh later on then we'll have to take a
look at the software itself okay that's
what shap is okay
um is pretty much an improvement on the
idea of a shaft and sampling value and
then along the way uh you know we'll go
ahead we will get some practice you know
we'll go through some exercises uh and
some of the links to the workbooks
uh there are some exercises that we'll
have you do something kind of get some
hands-on practice you will kind of go
over some some real-world
implementations
and you know specific specific answers
um you can go ahead questions you can
answer
sorry with the software itself and then
we'll go ahead and then wrap everything
up after that
okay
so that's what we're going to be going
ahead and doing and this will be very
very fun
and let's just jump right in okay
right so uh definitely i think if you
look at a lot of the workshops here at
pi data you know there are usually kind
of several themes that are recurrent
throughout the whole you know the whole
event uh definitely one i hear that you
see now is interpretable ml right in
various ways how to understand models
you know to make them more easily
explains uh you know maybe to prevent
bias you know to better understand where
they might work well or not work well
okay
so this has definitely become a very
important theme as machine learning has
become more prevalent right um i don't
think this is going to go away
all right and then like i mentioned here
previously all right
when it comes to model interpretation
there kind of is this fundamental
tension okay
uh you can see on one hand
we have older fashion models all right
uh these are usually grounded in
traditional statistics so things like uh
know linear regression is probably the
primary example uh which is still
probably uh the most commonly used
statistical technique uh used around
industry in various ways
okay uh simpler models
typically are not as powerful for
finding generalizable patterns inside
your data okay
they're just not their learning
technique tends to be a bit on the
shallow side
but one of their big benefits though is
that being able to interpret these
models is typically fairly
straightforward
okay so once you go ahead and you fit
them you have pretty clear explanations
in terms of what's happening
all right on the other end of the
spectrum uh you have models that are
more complicated okay
their pattern recognition capabilities
are definitely stronger and greater
okay however though it's very very
difficult to be able to map inputs to
outputs
okay so therefore right you might have
something that's highly accurate uh but
it can be very very difficult to really
understand exactly what's causing your
results all right and so people
typically are going to be slow to trust
uh you know things where they don't
actually understand how and why they
work
okay
likewise you know if these sorts of
models have certain blind spots or
biases or areas where they won't perform
well it's perhaps a bit more difficult
to understand that if you can't actually
understand what's going on the inside
all right so if you want a few examples
of each
all right so things like linear and
logistic regression naive bayes and
exponential smoothing are probably good
examples of simpler models
they're still widely used and lots of
times they are very very helpful in a
lot of circumstances i'm not saying
they're invalid or it'd always be a bad
idea to use them
but rather just their learning technique
is a bit on the shallow side
okay complicated models uh which are
becoming all the rage these days uh
definitely you know probably uh they're
covered in more detail something like pi
data right so things like uh neural
networks and then various types of tree
based models right so random forests or
uh you know gradient boosting machines
okay these things do tend to give you
better results okay
they have more elaborate pattern
matching criteria but of course it's a
little bit difficult to kind of
understand exactly how they impact
results
okay
so it's generally been the case right as
machine learning um has become more and
more prevalent
as compute power right has become larger
and larger and larger our data has
gotten bigger
okay
the distance between machine learning
models and more traditional models has
gotten wider and wider and wider okay
so therefore uh the performance benefit
they give you right becomes more salient
see it's more relevance but the same
time but also means the need to actually
understand them has actually gotten much
larger
okay
so kind of a good example here when it
comes to maybe just the dominance right
a complicated ml models compared to more
uh regular means
i'm going to go ahead and post a link
here on the zoom if you want to look at
it
uh these sorts of slides uh actually
sorry these sorts of studies tend to
come up i think fairly often
um but this is probably one of the most
comprehensive
all right uh the title of the paper was
an empirical comparison of supervised
learning algorithms using different
performance metrics
uh this was very very widely cited it
has over 2000 citations
so what it did
you know look at eight different data
sets um went ahead and used nine
different metrics
uh the total number of models that are
used i believe was actually 2 000
but in terms of the ones that they
actually ranked it was 30 okay and this
kind of ranged anywhere from simple you
know a linear regression you know to a
deep neural network okay
and then the overall results
okay uh we're pretty lopsided um the top
five performing models across the nine
metrics
all right uh we're all complicated
meaning they're either deep neural
networks or tree based ensembles okay
boosted decision trees did particularly
well if you look they took the top two
spots
all right and then also if you look at
any of the individual categories
uh same thing uh the highest performing
model and every single unique scoring
metric was also a complicated model okay
i think anyone who's worked a lot with
ml is not really surprised by this okay
uh the reason why ml is a thing right is
because their pattern finding
capabilities really are pretty robust
all right so i don't think this was an
unusual example and i think lots of
instances in real life uh these results
have played out in a similar way okay
generally speaking if you really want to
understand patterns that are within your
data
uh bigger you know more performant black
box machine learning models uh are
typically just going to give you a
better results to work with but of
course
uh the reason why they give you good
results is also why it's difficult maybe
to kind of understand what they're doing
okay
because they don't offer exact
analytical solutions okay uh they're
approximate solutions all right and so
it turns out in practice
you know um you know
approximate solutions are usually going
to outperform analytical ones
okay uh simply just due to the nature of
the data that they're studying
all right but still i've noticed in a
lot of circumstances okay
more complicated models oftentimes are
not always used as often as they ought
to be and the big reason why is because
people like to understand with a certain
level of precision
um you know how they might actually be
able to expect the results to be okay so
a lot of times uh a model that's not
particularly good or powerful but is
easily explained uh sometimes will get
more airplay than it deserves all right
so i currently you know i work with some
companies who work in finance
uh this might come as a surprise to
people but in finance uh linear
regression is actually still used pretty
extensively
okay not without good reason all right
because a lot of underlying financial
theory is actually based off of linear
models if anyone's familiar with the
capital asset pricing model you know or
three factor investing models you know
that came from like the chicago school
of investment theory things like that um
all this is kind of based off of doing
various forms of linear regression
but in any event uh one of the big
benefits right of linear regression is
that you can kind of quantify your
results very very carefully you know and
so there are a lot of careful
experimental designs you know for
different types of setups and things
along those lines and so it gives
practitioners an easy way to communicate
results
to people who might have a stake in an
investment they don't really understand
the quantitative methods themselves okay
so i for me i think a slide here or
comic uh that actually captures the
sentiment pretty well
all right is you might have something
like this right where sometimes you're
using a model which is not particularly
powerful for capturing the patterns
inside your data
but it does kind of allow you to talk
about um your results with a certain
level of precision even if those results
themselves aren't particularly good okay
you know so things like confidence
intervals okay you know estimates of
uncertainty
okay
you know statistical significance you
know things like that
all these things i think tend to be very
comforting to people who are at the helm
of like a decision and maybe they can't
actually understand at a practitioner's
level what's actually going on behind
the model artifacts okay
right so in this case right we should
mention we have a forecast you know to
say you know we predict there's going to
be a little over four million dollars in
sales
okay and of course we actually think
this is accurate but we can kind of sort
of say like our results you know can
kind of sort of have like this
particular confidence interval to them
uh you know level significance things
along those lines and so there's a
reporting framework around the model
results uh which often is very very
important uh as much as sort of like the
predictions themselves
okay
so in any event uh this framework tends
to be pretty powerful
uh there are a lot of industries you
know like finance like insurance
uh you know maybe certain types of you
know government agencies
um where the models that they use are
actually governed by how interpretable
uh they are
okay and so literally regardless of what
kind of results that they're going to
get if you're doing something like
credit scoring okay uh where maybe
you're approving or disapproving loan
applicants you have to be able to
explain why you're getting your results
to people okay and if you can't do that
it doesn't really matter how accurate
the results are okay so for this reason
there are quite a few industries uh who
stick to things that are very very well
understood even they they're probably
some other solutions which might be more
beneficial in terms of improving their
bottom line
okay so
in any event interpretability and lots
of different types of corporate context
uh definitely kind of applies some some
elbow grease to being able to use
various types of methods okay it
legitimizes uh lots of different
techniques
okay
so that kind of brings us to where we're
at right now okay so you have
complicated non-linear i don't like to
use the term black box you know but it's
a common term
okay so if we're using the vernacular of
the day right um so this idea of being
able to use highly powered models but
then also have some capacity to
understand their inputs um i think it's
just really really important obviously
if you're doing kaggle competitions or
if you're at some kind of ai startup or
things like that you know you can just
kind of use your your biggest baddest
neural network or whatever and call it a
day
but for lots of other companies right
that are trying to kind of incorporate
ml into the regular business practices
that's not necessarily going to fly
right away
okay
so currently uh you know there are some
solutions uh that are often put in place
you know for understanding uh non-linear
models
uh the most important one is feature
importance you notice this is you know
if you fit a random forest you know or a
gradient boosted machine i believe you
can do this with a neural network as
well the idea is what you can do then
all right
uh you can randomly shuffle the values
in certain columns and then look to see
how much your model performance is
affected by
and just kind of sort of uh you know sum
up and average the absolute value of the
effect
okay and so you typically you know if
you're done something like slide kit
learn when you're done fitting your
model you have something kind of like
this you know where each individual
column inside your data set uh you know
how much of the the model performance
was attributed to each individual column
there are some other things you can do
as well like partial dependence if
anyone's familiar with that okay but
this is typically uh kind of like the
first step that people often take when
it comes to understanding model results
um this is not a bad thing right so uh
what we're looking at over here right
our future importance is for the boston
housing data set
if anyone's not familiar with it is
probably the most commonly used data set
you know for under that kind of studying
regression problems it's extremely
common it's built into scikit-learn lots
of other libraries okay and so we're
seeing over here right uh columns you
know that represent different aspects of
information about a house
you know and so if you regress you know
all these things against housing prices
it turns out number of rooms
and then uh something called lsat which
is percentage of population that's low
socioeconomic status you know account
for 80 of the results okay and then all
these things kind of add up to 100 at
the very end all right
as this kind of tells you right
something like room has the most
importance followed by lsat and your
distance things like that
this is okay it's not too bad um it's
kind of like the standard output you
know for these sorts of things if you're
dealing with a non-linear model uh
there's a lot of information there this
does not tell you okay
it tells you the absolute level of the
importance uh but it doesn't actually
give you the sign
okay if overall you know
values in this column tend to push it
upward or downward
okay
it doesn't really tell you about
individual values okay within your data
set which is often very important okay
so this is a global interpretation of
your data set but oftentimes you need
local interpretations okay
so for a particular circumstance right
uh how much is one particular value you
know gonna go ahead and impact the
results one way or the other okay this
tells you nothing about that
okay
and so collectively
all right um you know these three
shortcomings actually
make it kind of a tough sell
to use a model like this you know um
when this is kind of all the output that
you can get from it now of course you
know there's been a lot of improvement
on this in the last couple years you
know shop is kind of one of the the big
supports with that you know but there
are some other libraries as well uh so
it's becoming less and less true that
future importance is all that you have
at your disposal but again it's kind of
like the standard ground zero i'm kind
of like um you know stuff you might take
from model interpretation
it's it's kind of weak sauce okay there
are a lot of things it's not going to be
able to do
all right and so really being able to
overcome these shortcomings is by things
like shop and then other advancements in
interpol ml have kind of gained some
retraction recently
all right so with that said
okay
uh when it comes to understanding uh
non-linear models okay
um something that's a little bit a
little strange about it okay
um something that's fundamentally
different about something like a
gradient boosted model or a neural
network and something like linear
regression okay
if you have a simple model okay when
you're done fitting it the model gives
you both the prediction and the
explanation itself wrapped up into one
okay like you don't actually have to go
beyond the model itself right to get
that information so once you fit it then
you're done
all right what's a little bit tricky
about interpretable ml for non-linear
models okay
is you actually need two separate models
okay the one that you use to fit your
data on okay to make your predictions or
whatever
okay and then what you need then
is a separate model to explain the model
that you fit
okay
so it's kind of the derivative model or
the secondary model whatever you want to
go and call it okay so once you're done
with something like a random forest or a
neural network okay uh then you need to
go ahead and apply an additional
technique uh to make sure you can
understand um how different values are
contributing to the output
okay
it's a little bit difficult maybe to
wrap your head around right so the model
for the model right to make sure you
understand what's happening with it uh
but if you actually want explainable ml
this is basically what you have to do
okay
uh so when it comes okay to what kind of
properties
okay uh an explainer model i should have
uh there are basically three separate
criteria okay uh that you need to be
able to meet all right
all right the first criteria is called
local accuracy
all right uh local accuracy is basically
kind of built around this idea
um that if you actually add up all of
the contributions right from your
individual features
uh they should actually basically equal
uh your final model's prediction
right so meaning if you kind of take
your final prediction and then break it
down into all of its individual
components and then you add them back up
uh there should be a certain parity all
right between the two
okay uh missingness
basically kind of states that if you
have an unimportant feature removing it
from your model shouldn't impact the
results okay
and then consistency
all right basically states that uh if
you have a particular value in a column
and you hold everything else constant
uh increasing it or decreasing it uh you
should be able to see uh the influence
of that particular value or feature kind
of change um in accordance with it
okay
if you want maybe uh something that's a
bit more tactile uh in concrete
okay
in terms of what these things mean
i have some slides over here if you
would like though
okay
you can go ahead and then go to the url
so what this is um this is you know an
ml application uh that was fit on a data
set of about four and a half million uh
different police stops and it's designed
to sort of understand uh what
contributes to a particular policing
outcome and so you kind of like put in
different values over here
uh the main idea though here this is
kind of a working example here of kind
of like what like um
you know a model interpreter should have
okay and if he's gonna go down and then
hit run analysis here at the very end uh
you'll be brought to the screen
okay which is kind of um the chance of
arrest for a person these particular
circumstances okay
but in any event if you just kind of
want like the screen that's going to
match the slides here okay
you can go ahead if you go down here and
hit run analysis you'll get the result
and that will have basically give you a
screen that's matching
what i have on my own slides
all right so the basic idea here
all right
uh local accuracy
okay is basically built around the idea
all right if you add up uh the final
overall contributions of each individual
column
okay it should actually give you okay
the final model prediction uh that you
that you're working with so in this case
all right
uh you know in this case we're starting
with the baseline value of 35
in terms of an expected outcome
all right
if you actually add up
okay the contributions of each
individual future value inside the model
itself right ten seven negative six
negative five one you know five nine up
here okay it should add up to this right
over here okay so this idea of
completeness okay so
uh the final model prediction can be
cleanly broken down into its individual
components and then if you add up the
individual components
uh you end up with your model's final
prediction
okay uh that's what local accuracy is
okay
uh missingness okay right same thing
um if you have a column which is
basically a low impact
uh that means removing that column uh
from your data set shouldn't really
impact model results very much okay so
in this case
uh if you're at the police x-ray website
okay basically what it's saying for this
particular outcome the quarter of the
year really had no influence okay on the
predicted probability
of this particular person's outcome
with the police so what that should mean
then
if you remove the quarter column from
your data set uh your model's prediction
shouldn't be influenced at all because
it shouldn't have any impact
okay so that's what missingness is okay
and then finally here
okay when it comes to consistency it
just means if you hold everything else
constant and then you change one
particular value uh the influence of
that particular value or column
should go up or down uh in relation to
it okay so in this case
all right
if you compare the screen that i have
right over here
okay uh with the one uh they had
previously
okay the inputs are all the same okay
uh someone got in automobile accidents
right they're from the city of charlotte
it's the second quarter of the year
monday
okay it's at noon right over here uh
only difference though
okay the value of age
okay went from 40 to 50 okay
okay so meaning here
all right we held everything else
constant okay now these other values are
different
okay we changed the value though okay
from 40 to 50
okay and then if you rerun the analysis
okay uh the overall influence okay of
the age value
uh gets appropriately larger
okay so in this case right uh the
contribution uh to the final prediction
uh went from about a magnitude of five
percent to magnitude of nine percent
okay
now obviously how much something will
change uh will depend um
uh you will depend exactly on you know
the actual importance of the column
itself but that same basic property uh
should be
should be true okay
um we're gonna just you know i really
like the questions in the chat that's
awesome okay
um i'm gonna say though probably we're
gonna do is we're gonna have a few
breaks uh throughout the presentation
uh to kind of kind of go over and answer
everyone's questions uh so i think
yannick's question is awesome you know
what a shop use the data source we're
actually going to talk about that
explicitly
uh here in a few minutes we kind of get
into the details uh so that's coming up
um
buzz and in general though anyone who
has any questions like that feel free to
put them in the zoom chat but we'll
probably go ahead and then kind of
circle around them
uh you know kind of answer them in one
bulk uh just just to economize on time
okay
all right so in any event
all right uh moving forward
all right so in terms of you know some
kind of explanatory model
all right local accuracy
okay missingness
okay and then consistency okay a lot of
these things i think are basically
common sense
okay i think they would probably seem
fairly intuitive to us but in terms of
maybe some
that in terms of explicit criteria that
a model would have to meet
in order to be able to adequately
explain something
uh these are kind of the three pillars
you should be able to go ahead and shoot
for
okay
so with that being said uh this brings
us to shop
okay
uh which i actually think it's a
somewhat twisted acronym
okay what it actually stands for is
shapley additive explanations
okay
uh so in any event uh this was a newer
technique that was developed at the
university of washington fairly recently
i believe in 2017's when they first
broke ground with it uh their more
polished implementation i didn't really
come around to about 2019
and it's definitely had a very very big
impact over the last two years or so
okay
um so the idea here
uh it is
a game theoretic way
okay to explain uh the contributions of
any particular model okay regardless of
how it arrives at its answers
okay
um when you're computing a shop value
all right
there are really two fundamental kind of
theorems or ideas that are kind of kind
of powering its results
okay one is game theory
uh which is actually i think not very
intuitive uh when i think of game theory
i think of maybe military generals
uh you know kind of uh talking about
different types of strategy to take or
maybe executives in a boardroom or maybe
plants you know in biology how they
might kind of you know change their
evolutionary adaptations to get more
sunlight things along those lines i
don't really think about machine
learning models as really being an
application of game theory uh but it
turns out that's not the case okay and
so there's actually important game
theory involved
in in computing shaft values
uh the second one is a more traditional
machine learning concept and that's
permutation
okay
uh permutation is a very common way of
developing statistical inference uh for
non-parametric models
uh it's basically built around the idea
is that by deliberately changing the
arrangement of certain items within a
system
uh it's actually a way to measure
something's impacts
you know or maybe in a more plain
english if you remove something and see
what changes it kind of tells you what
the overall importance of that
particular value or column
okay
so what we're gonna do here uh we're
gonna go to a notebook here pretty soon
to kind of walk through a shop
computation and sort of like with first
steps let's kind of talk about uh some
of the basic ideas okay
in terms of how this actually applies to
shaft
so shaft stands for something called
shapley additive explanation okay
um if you actually do some research
something called a shapley value
is a very very kind of old-fashioned
concept and game theory
okay about how to distribute payouts to
different players that are competing for
some particular price
okay um that sounds kind of vague here
particularly right when it comes to
something like ml or data science
okay but the way you would actually
frame this
okay in terms of a model right
is that essentially all right uh the
players in our game
are the individual columns or features
within our data set
okay
um here we're looking at kind of a kind
of a tabular data set
uh even if you had unstructured data
like an image or text
the same basic idea would apply okay um
you know if you had an image you could
basically think of every single
individual pixel or groups of pixels
right as being a particular player
all right
and then essentially the prize all right
um that these players are competing for
is the overall predicted value itself
all right
and then in terms of payouts right for
competing for a prize
okay the payout
okay is basically the contribution that
gets allocated to each individual
feature for the model's predictions
okay so if we're at the police x-ray
website and we kind of go ahead run
analysis okay
uh that will basically tell you right
the amount of payout that's being
allocated
uh to each individual column for that
particular prediction
all right this is kind of uh kind of the
basic idea of game theory uh that's
going inside the calculation okay and so
this is really where shackley comes from
okay so it turns out uh there's kind of
an important idea called a sharply
sampling value uh which is really kind
of the the basis for shop itself as a
way to kind of contribute payouts in a
very very um you know robust and
consistent manner regardless of what
kind of situation that you're in okay so
when you hear something about shop right
it's just kind of based off these game
theoretic foundations
uh that's what it's referring to
okay
now how these payouts okay are actually
computed okay for each of the individual
features within your data set
all right that's where permutation comes
in
all right
so in this case all right
what's happening very very specifically
all right imagine you have two samples
in your data set
okay sample one sample two all right
and you wanna be able to calculate okay
the influence
in this case let's say something inside
the room column right which is 6.575
right so how much is something like that
okay contributing you know to whatever
your model's prediction is
all right so the way permutation works
okay and computing a shapley value
all right i call them franken samples
okay but you can call them something
else if you want to
essentially what you do is all right
if you're trying to calculate okay uh
shackley sampling value basically
shaftly contributions for this
particular sample
you would randomly sample
okay on something else from your data
set
all right and then what you would do
then is you would make a hybrid
combination between the two
okay so we look at this right over here
all right
um the bottom five values are all drawn
from sample one
okay uh the rest of the samples are
drawn from sample two okay so each of
these samples are basically spliced
together uh from the two previous ones
uh but if you're calculating okay the
contribution right of the value of room
what you would do then here
is you would deliberately all right in
one sample use the value of room from
sample one
and then in the other sample okay i use
the value from sample two
okay
so this is kind of a random hodgepodge
of two samples but with one particular
column deliberately held separate
all right
and then what you do then
is you take the difference in
predictions all right between sample one
and sample two
all right that would give you some kind
of number
all right is the idea is for that
particular permutation
okay that would be the marginal
contribution right of changing the value
of room in this case with six point four
two to 6.57
all right the idea though all right
if you do this over and over and over
again okay continually drawing random
samples from your training set
okay
and then also
if you continually draw different random
combination of columns in each of the
two samples
and then you go ahead take the
differences and then average them out
that will give you the marginal
contribution okay
of that particular value inside your
data set okay relative to all the other
possibilities
okay and so that calculation okay when
done through all of your individual
columns for all of your individual
samples is what a sharply sampling value
is okay
uh we're actually going to go ahead and
then see this okay
prevented
um so keep in mind
so okay i'll go over a few things over
here so one thing over here about the
sampling okay something about the slide
itself
okay if you look over here the
differences between these two samples is
actually quite subtle
all right and so it is actually
important detail okay to go ahead and
then wrap your head around so if you
look at frank in sample one right over
here okay
and then if you look at sample one right
over here okay the big thing here
okay
the columns crime through knox
okay
basically belong to sample one
however though if you look at the values
for age right over here
okay
and you know what i actually did make
simple two uh there is actually a little
bit of a mistake on my slide i apologize
here
okay so excuse me you know what thank
you for pointing this out uh important
detail here uh essentially what should
have happened here i'm sorry i actually
apologize for this
okay uh the top here should all be from
sample one the bottom here should all be
from sample two i actually made a
mistake this is a typo so thank you for
pointing it out
okay and then the two things that are
deliberately held separate
okay
should be the values of room right over
here okay so
i believe he pointed out was
was ilya so thank you yeah there is an
error on the slide
okay uh and so i i appreciate that so
yeah so down over here right right over
here uh these values should match okay
uh but i overlooked that one creating
that so thank you for pointing it out so
everyone here is making a kind of a
mental note right
uh these values should match from sample
one and on the bottom over here
uh either 78.9 the 4.96 the 2 the 2.42
whatever okay all these these
should actually match over here
okay see the random mix between sample
one sample two
and then the things that are
deliberately held different are the
values of a room if we were to calculate
the shaft with sampling value
okay for for the room column itself
okay
um so
again we'll actually i think we'll
probably round up some of these uh
answers to these questions um
um
as when we uh
when we kind of finish up this next
slide here okay we're gonna get anybody
to a point where we're gonna go ahead
and then answer a few things
um what we're gonna do though here
everyone if you wouldn't mind
okay
is let's go to this link right over here
it should be in the slack channel
okay also if you go over here um i can
go ahead i think uh rose if you want to
go ahead and put it inside the zoom chat
as well
okay it should be further up in the zoom
chat
okay we want to go ahead we can click
on this link
uh this is going to give us kind of like
a kind of a sample calculation okay
of a shapley value okay
uh and then we'll kind of talk about
specifically how how shap takes this
and then um and it kind of improves upon
it okay and in different ways
okay but this is kind of like the the
core sharply uh sampling value which is
kind of uh the game theoretic foundation
of shaft itself
all right so
uh the notebook itself should be called
uh sharply sampling values
uh you should be brought to something in
google collab
uh real quick if you want to run this on
your own
all right you should be able to go ahead
and go to file and then click on save a
copy and drive okay and that'll take it
uh somewhere where it's local
okay if you want to go ahead and then
run this yourself i would definitely
recommend that
okay i probably make it a bit more
tactile you can kind of see how these
things work firsthand
all right so what we're going to do here
um
you know we're just going to take a look
right kind of like a sample uh sharply
computation okay what it looks like um
this is the unmodified version of it as
well okay
uh you know without any sort of um
additional optimizations
okay yeah so same thing right uh real
quick it's worth pointing out here so we
just make sure we can run it ourselves
file
save a copy and drive okay and that
should go ahead and then save you a
local copy and then you can go ahead and
run that
all right so what we're gonna do
uh one thing you might need to do here
first also
you know actually in fact i don't even
think you're going to need shot for this
so if you want to you can probably just
going to go ahead and then comment this
out
uh because this notebook actually
doesn't even actually use any shop
okay uh we're kind of doing it from
scratch here
so we'll import numpy pandas okay we're
gonna load in the boston data set
and then again uh shapley is model
agnostic
yeah
um and
and then go from there okay so you can
basically uh an important detail about
uh shapley's value is that it looks at
differences in predictions by permuting
different combinations of values uh so
it doesn't actually really care or pay
attention to sort of what's happening
inside the model itself which is why
it's model agnostic
okay in any event okay so we have numpy
we have pandas we're importing our data
set um so same thing this is very
boilerplate stuff we don't really care
about the model so much right now all
right so what we're doing here okay um
we're loading in x and y okay we're
gonna go ahead and fit
sure so i think mentioned
let me know if this helps if it's more
legible
okay great okay all right so loading
this in okay again we're not really
going to talk about the modeling so much
or how to get better performance out of
a random forest or whatever okay uh
that's not really the purpose of of this
of this uh you know this workshop all
right we're gonna take a look at the
head of x
okay
uh it's the same thing if we're not from
this is a very common data set uh
probably the most commonly used one you
know for for looking at regression
problems uh so the idea is you know this
is data set about 500 different houses
that were sold in the greater boston
area and so you have 13 columns which
basically describe um
uh you know different characteristics of
a housing neighborhood what is sold for
okay so if we're at all curious it's
just things like the crime rates and
then the you know the room and the age
of the house and things like tax rates
and that sort of stuff
okay
um so now the idea then all right with
this particular data set and then we
have a model that's fit on it okay
what we're going to go ahead and do here
is actually kind of walk through um
computing
okay
an actual sharply sampling bag okay
and this is kind of like the base
computation
that's used inside shop okay
with quite a few enhancements okay but
this is kind of like the kind of the
basic funnel that's going on okay so
what we're gonna do here
okay
um we're saving a few variables uh we
are saving the columns and x okay and
then we're also making a copy of that
because a big part of what a shapley
sampling value is
is randomly shuffling uh the combination
of columns that are being used inside
the franken samples okay
uh because an important idea of sort of
how it kind of arrives at its value
um is that uh every single time uh you
actually get two random franken samples
they have different combination of
columns in each one okay which kind of
allows you to measure you know the
contribution of a particular value
relative to different combinations of
columns which is something that's
typically done to help combat your
multicollinearity which is mentioned in
one of the questions
okay another question like how many runs
or how many permutations do you have to
do
okay the answer is to get the exact
value uh you have to do a lot
okay in practice though uh what you do
is uh you do enough until you get some
kind of convergence
all right and basically where uh the
additional improvements uh of like kind
of basically yeah the additional
improvements or your additional change
and the sharply sampling value basically
uh falls below some sort of threshold
uh we're making additional iterations
doesn't really have any kind of
improvement
okay and so basically in this case to
calculate um a single shaft value
okay we're going to go ahead
all right and then go through a thousand
runs
all right and then uh this just the
index that we're going to sample from
extra
okay so let's run these variables let's
run this notebook over here
okay so now the idea then what we're
going to do
is we're going to go ahead
and we're going to calculate okay
sharply sampling values for one
particular sample
okay just one okay which in this case is
going to be the very very first row of
the data set
okay and so that's what x is going to be
right over here
okay
then what we're going to do here
okay
um we're going to randomly sample
another value from from x okay which is
we're going to call j all right
so x is basically going to stay the same
throughout this exercise
uh j is going to continually be
different okay so every single run okay
j is going to represent
a different value
all right so if you want to if you just
kind of want to inspect these things
okay we can see the differences between
x and j
okay and and what they're meant to do
okay
and again this is for demonstration
purposes if you just kind of want to
take a look at these things and see what
they're doing
all right
uh this is kind of important detail
right we talked about like permutation
um so this is kind of where it's
happening right over here so what we're
doing here this our list of columns
okay
and then we are randomly shuffling this
okay
and we do this okay every single time we
do it all right because an important
part about shapley sampling is again you
have different combinations of columns
coming from from sample one and sample
two so what we're going to do
we're going to go ahead and randomly
shuffle our columns
all right and then we're going to
reorder right samples j and sample x
okay according to that new random order
of columns
okay
now these next lines right over here
okay we're initializing two different
variables okay
um according to kind of the literature
you should look at the official paper
right for schaffy's sampling um you
would call this you know x m plus j x
minus j
so again i'll sort of answer a bunch of
questions while uh we actually in a few
minutes here we'll we'll beat a decent
spot
okay um so kind of one thing i want to
go ahead and bring our attention to here
okay
is uh we have xm plus j and then xm
minus j right over here notice here what
we're doing
okay
we're saying
okay starting at the room column
okay set all the samples in this one
equal to j
okay but make the value for room itself
equal to the value in x
okay and then over here in the next
variable
we're basically doing the exact same
thing
okay but we are knitting omitting rather
this one particular separate over here
okay so the idea then
okay these two samples right over here x
m plus j x minus j okay
by basically saying uh make everything
from room onwards okay equal to what's
in j but they're sending the one and x
right over here
all right uh what we have is something
that is functionally equivalent
okay to our two franken samples
okay
and so what you'll see over here right
again there's a mistake in my slide uh
because these two values should mature
over here okay but so basically we have
now is uh we have two samples right
we're the top one right over here right
all the values from sample one the
bottom all from sample two
but we've deliberately i kind of changed
the two values right and room over here
six point five seven five and then six
point four two right over there okay so
the idea then
all right
these are our two values
all right so again if we want to inspect
them that we can
right so they have shared combinations
of the two individual samples but the
values for room are deliberately held
separate okay
so now the idea then
okay
uh this next step that we're going to do
over here
is we're just going to kind of go ahead
all right
and then this is kind of formatting it
to make it ready for predictions
all right so then what you do then
all right is you look at the differences
in predicted values okay for the two
individual samples
okay and so the idea is for these two
particular samples
uh this is the marginal contribution of
kind of going from taking the value of
room from one thing to the other
relative to all the additional columns
all right
so now the idea then okay this is just
one particular sample okay it's just not
like you just do this once and then
you're done
uh the whole part about like sharply
sampling okay and firm mutation is that
you kind of have to go through this
process okay a number of times and then
you average out the differences
okay
so uh what this next line does over here
okay uh basically we'll go ahead take
all these steps that we just did
okay and then put them into a loop
all right so if we go ahead and run this
all right
now someone had a question so sort of
you know how many runs do you have to do
you know things like that okay you know
there's kind of a heuristic
uh where typically anywhere from a 500
to a thousand i will typically be
adequate okay but also the way these
things are implemented
is they have you know something kind of
like a tolerance level you know where
after they've done so many runs and so
basically no more improvement is being
done above a certain threshold uh then
it'll go ahead and then turn itself off
okay
but you'll see here an important part
about sharply sampling okay is that it
is an approximation technique okay
it's based off of random sampling uh
which means you'll converge uh towards
whatever the true marginal contribution
is
for that particular column value
but unless you run the whole thing into
perpetuity uh you won't get there
entirely
okay
so the idea then okay once you're done
okay you have all of your individual
shaft values and then you divide that
you know um by
the number of runs that you did and
that's basically the monte carlo
approximation of the shaft value for
that particular column for the sample
all right so we run through this
again uh it probably is going to be a
little bit different for different
people but again as you sort of did more
runs uh this would eventually go ahead
and then converge towards the same thing
okay uh so what we're gonna do now if
you go to the next line
okay this would basically kind of go
ahead and do the same step
okay except do it for every single
individual column
okay
and again this is gonna go ahead and
take a while to run
all right
uh so let's go ahead if you want to
let's run this
all right uh this is gonna take a while
okay this would probably be a good time
uh just to kind of go ahead and then
walk through and then answer
uh various types of questions okay
okay
so i'm gonna try and start from the top
here uh one question that we got is sort
of you know what's required you know to
compute the value
you know uh things like that okay
uh so here hopefully after doing this
all right uh the answers may be a bit
more clear
uh you actually need all of your
training data
yeah
and then uh so yes you basically need
your training data to derive the sharply
value okay which is actually a little
something uh something of a drawback
okay in practice uh because it means
it's a bit more computationally intense
okay
uh because you kind of have to sort of
you fit your model and then you kind of
like kind of almost
uh reused the model pretty extensively
to derive uh the shackley value itself
all right and then uh the good question
here in um from from zoom here yeah so
uh shapley basically works yeah on both
you beat both the randomly generated
samples from your training data
uh and you also you do need the model
itself
okay
all right a few questions uh came up
about like non-collinearity and things
along those lines okay
uh generally speaking okay
uh sharply does assume uh
non-collinearity
uh in practice though there are actually
ways to calculate different types of
interaction effects okay between
different types of columns uh one other
thing uh which typically is useful with
sharply as well is every single run
all right you have different
combinations of columns
okay so in practice uh when you're
actually kind of calculating out the
change right from doing going from one
value to the other
uh you're actually uh comparing that uh
to the particular values in certain
types of columns and so because the sets
of columns that you're calculating the
sharply value against changes from every
single time
it typically does do a good job of
separating out potential interaction
effects and then getting something for
that particular column itself yeah but
shapley value all by itself basically
does kind of assume you have this
independent effect for every single
column
okay uh one thing we're going to go
ahead and talk about
when we talk about shaft in particular
is
uh basically how you calculate
interaction of x and so it turns out
what you can do is you can calculate uh
sharply values jointly with different
combinations of columns and then
subtract out the differences to kind of
get the main effect
uh and then contributing effects from
individual columns so there's a bit of
an improvement on that with the actual
shaft software library but shot by a
shaftly sampling value by itself
is is going to be
is going to assume uh independence
between the columns
okay uh so
no so let's take a look a few more
questions here
[Music]
all right so we have multi collinearity
uh we have you know the issue about sort
of uh what you actually need uh to
compute the sampling value
uh another question that came up here um
so what if rankin sampling creates
totally illogical samples you can just
be prevented
uh the answer is for the most part uh
not entirely okay
uh but the idea of the whole point of
sampling though is that you actually go
through enough iterations that it kind
of gives you uh basically uh you know
different sorts of contributions from a
very very wide variety of combinations
uh within your data set and then
anything
that you would do right from from shaft
would actually just be drawn from your
training data itself
uh so it is true uh you probably would
get some fairly uh you know weird or
erratic values occasionally uh but the
whole point of the marty counter
sampling is to kind of average those
things out
okay
yeah um so actually another question
here so
uh the shaft library can compute the
shapley values given a single example uh
so what we're actually doing right now
is we're actually uh the actual training
loop that we just ran okay uh that might
be in your jupiter notebooks is actually
calculating the sharply values for a
single sample
okay uh so one thing to kind of jump out
to you uh sharply sampling all by itself
without any other improvements is
actually fairly slow
okay which is one of the reasons why it
hasn't really taken off
okay
let's take a look at some more questions
okay
one is uh so do 35 of police office in
north carolina actually result in
arrests
uh the answer to that is no uh for
whatever it's worth
um there were different types of weights
uh that were reapplied to positive
instances in the data set
to make sure feature interactions were
basically kind of discovered more
carefully
in practice i
the actual amount of police stops that
actually result in arrest is closer to
about two or three percent
okay uh but that particular application
was built to sort of make sure um
interactions between different features
uh was more vividly kind of like
clarified
um and so therefore uh the um the
positive samples for arrests or stops
were actually upsampled uh considerably
which is why the base uh base prediction
itself is actually a little bit
different all right that's more about
the actual uh application that we were
using not actually chamfering itself
um so
jessica has a question here
okay do you have three loops
creating lots of frankincense samples uh
holding your heater's constant do this
for each feature loop over all second
samples if you actually look at the
actual code snippet that's running
you take a look over here okay uh there
are just two loops
okay uh so we're looping through each
column and then for each column you know
we're generating the different samples
and then within right over here we're
creating a new uh random selection right
over here so
you do get a new random choice
rather a new random combination of
columns
on each individual run
but i would say it's probably done
inside the loop itself
versus kind of uh as kind of it's sort
of its own individual looper over here
but they're just two loop but within one
uh we always generate the new random
combination of columns
yeah so uh shop itself
uh we're gonna talk about what it does
is it actually kind of takes the idea of
shockwave sampling um and then kind of
co-ops it uh specifically uh for
different types of ml models that are
commonly used
okay and so for example here um like if
you're doing a tree based model uh it
would actually uh basically generate uh
the sharpness values from the individual
nodes inside the tree so you wouldn't
actually just need uh training like
values specifically within the training
itself uh it could be uh calculated uh
on the fly
okay
yeah and one hot encoding uh this came
up a few different ways
uh one hot encoding uh would also more
or less uh be fine
okay uh where it would uh you'd
basically yeah just kind of go ahead and
then uh just change something from from
zero to one or one to zero and then just
test that against different combinations
of columns
it turns out to just so you know uh
randomly shuffling the columns uh means
the number of potential permutations you
could use for any sort of sample are
actually quite large okay uh they're
they're they're pretty doggone big okay
uh so it turns out uh shackles sampling
on its own uh doesn't actually uh it's
it's logarithmic time
uh is is actually is is pretty high it
actually it's 2 to the power of k
factorial
yeah so it turns out we'll talk over
here
uh shot basically does kind of hold a
similar combination the pixels constant
at one time
okay
and then likewise also you can use it
for various types of interaction values
as well
to kind of calculate the joint effects
between multiple columns at one time and
not just one all by itself okay
um
in the interest of time i'm gonna go
ahead
okay and uh keep moving here
all right so the idea is uh once you're
done with this loop okay
uh you have a big combination right of
all these sampling values over here
okay and then the idea then
all right
uh if you average these out okay these
would be the average values okay
um
you know for this particular sample
right over here and so then the idea
then
all right if you look at this okay and
then you add up right the average value
right of each individual columns
okay and then compare that to the base
prediction right over here
uh you actually get something
uh that in practice is quite close to
your model's prediction
okay now again uh we didn't again this
is a sampling technique it's an
approximation method uh so
you know the idea is we actually didn't
cover like every single possible
permutation of columns
okay and then kind of calculate their
marginal contribution
but you can see here we converged uh
towards something that is that is pretty
close
okay
so
basic idea here uh what we just kind of
discussed let's kind of talk a little
bit
about uh so kind of what this means all
right in various contexts
okay
all right so
uh something that is useful okay about
sharply sampling
okay
again it actually does meet uh kind of
the criteria that we talked about before
okay um the only thing it really looks
at
okay are differences between uh you know
model predictions you know for different
types of franken samples so therefore it
doesn't really rely in any sort of
actually really any way at all
uh with respect to um you know what kind
of model that you're using okay so it is
a model agnostic method
okay uh generally speaking too all right
uh because you're constantly uh kind of
like calculating something against
different combinations of columns uh it
is pretty good at isolating uh the
independent effect from that particular
value
okay uh simply just by continually uh
computing it against you know sort of
like different types of random shuffles
uh again which will kind of indirectly
capture um your different types of
contributions uh from the different
columns over time okay so it is usually
pretty good at isolating the independent
effects
um however though there are a few things
which are a little troubling about it
okay
um they actually fully compute okay a of
the sampling value
uh it's actually fairly time consuming
okay
uh so if you see here
uh what it does uh the actual um you
know uh algorithmic time of it is
actually scales uh and two raise the k
factorial okay uh that number gets
pretty big okay in this case k is the
number of columns in your data set uh or
the number of features uh you want to go
ahead and then uh you calculate against
okay so um yeah so to kind of fully
calculate the exact exactly value would
be uh quite quite cumbersome
okay so therefore uh raw sharply
sampling by itself
okay i isn't always going to scale
especially well for all models
all right and the other things kind of
came back to a question that people had
all right
is it actually requires a kind of a full
um
full access to to your data
okay
uh which itself you know is is kind of a
problem okay
uh not every single uh model
interpretation technique uh does this
uh but in the case of something with
like sharply values uh you do kind of
have to keep on resampling from your
training data to capture the marginal
effect in various ways
okay
so in any event
okay
uh this kind of brings us to the actual
shop library
uh shop is based off of right the the
sharply technique which is actually been
around for for several decades you know
the actual shampoo sampling you know was
was uh derived and elaborated you know i
i think sometime like like nine age
early 2000's
okay
uh but what shapley does what shop does
actually allows um
co-ops the idea of sharply sampling
okay
um with other particular techniques
okay
uh to actually basically allow the
calculation of shackly values
uh but actually kind of co-opting other
types of model interpretation methods so
that way you have faster and more exact
ways of calculating sharply values uh
for wider varieties of model
okay
so in this case uh it turns out
um if anyone's familiar with kind of
like interpretable ml and things like
that uh there's things called uh if you
mention the chat a line a tree
interpreter
okay and then something for neural
networks called deep lift okay
all of these are basically ways to kind
of like understanding model output
okay
uh the shaft library uh basically takes
uh these different ways of kind of
basically uh kind of you know traversing
the model structure
uh different types of ml models and then
using uh those specific model structures
uh to calculate shackley values more
quickly
okay
uh so whereas it probably took our
codelab notebook you know a couple
minutes uh to kind of go and calculate
the sharply values from one sample
okay um shop eliza library allows you to
basically calculate sharply values more
quickly across a wider variety of
contexts
okay
and this is kind of its real
technological breakthrough
all right
so
again this approach it was written um by
primarily one person named scott
londberg uh who came from uh university
of washington
okay
and so the idea then uh shop is
basically a unified framework
um for basically calculating future
importance
okay across a wide variety of models
okay
and so it allows you to do things like
neural networks you know or gbms okay
and actually have uh very specific and
exact ways of calculating uh
contributions of of your input data
okay
uh and so that's really kind of the big
breakthrough is that sort of like
regardless of the model that you have
um you can basically have a shop value
with it uh that kind of allows you for
individual samples uh to understand uh
what contributes to that okay
so with that being said
uh let's go over here to our next
notebook
okay
um so sharply sampling is kind of like
more of the pure technique right how it
works
okay uh let's take a look at the shop
library itself
all right and again uh this is pretty
much a more performant way of doing what
we just did by hand okay that was the
old school way okay um but this way uh
we can kind of calculate uh shockley
values in a way
uh that is more specific uh towards
various types of models
all right so same thing uh for this
notebook uh you're probably lab does not
come with shop installed right out of
the box
all right so
uh if you will make sure you have this
line pip install shop right over here
okay so we'll go ahead and run it and
again uh we should go ahead and get shop
installed you know it takes a little bit
of time
okay
uh so again i'll kind of talk about here
so um you know shop is basically a more
flexible
uh and then faster implementation of
calculating shaft new sampling values
that are specific to different types of
models
um it's really it's two different things
wrapped up into one
all right it is a computational tool
all right uh it turns out you actually
no no so yeah you couldn't use it for
unsupervised learning you can use it for
unstructured data
okay like you can kind of calculate the
contributions of individual words or
groups of pixels or things like that
um but no you wouldn't actually be able
to use it for unsupervised learning
okay
okay
um
[Music]
shop is probably not as good a tool as
other things uh for performing feature
selection itself
okay uh rather i don't know that it
would actually contribute very much
uh that's something maybe just kind of
like standard feature importance uh wood
or woodens
uh for different i actually don't think
it's its primary purpose
it's actually just better for whatever
data that you have just kind of
understanding interactions within it you
could kind of do it for that because you
could actually look um
something with the low absolute chat
value throughout an entire data set
would be an unimportant feature and so
therefore you could use that as kind of
a choice you just said to remove
something from your your data set
um however i don't think uh it would
actually necessarily have a comparative
advantage uh compared to other
techniques for it
okay
uh in any event
so okay so we go ahead uh we import this
right over here okay it's the same thing
we're gonna kind of come up with kind of
like our our very simple model here
all right with uh boston
and then uh we'll go and do a random
forest regressor
okay
uh so big thing right um shop comes
uh with different built-in methods uh
for specific types of models okay
so basically there's something called
tree explainer uh which allows you to go
ahead and calculate shaft values in a
way that is very very particular for
decision tree based models
okay if you're dealing with neural
networks okay you have a deep explainer
okay which is the same thing uh which is
a little bit more kind of closely
attuned you know to performing uh you
know feature attributions for deep
models
um if you just want a model agnostic way
of calculating uh feature contributions
uh there's something called uh the
kernel explainer okay uh which is um
about on par
i think artem's a comment here is
probably i would kind of what i would
say too where like you could probably
get uh kind of similar results using
shaft as something else uh but i don't
i just don't know that it'll perform any
particular uh really comparative benefit
you know compared to other things that
you have at your disposal
okay
all right so in any event okay
um what's useful here
about about shop right it kind of gives
you
um a more faster more exact way of
calculating sharply values across a
wider variety of different models
all right and so the idea then
[Music]
it looks like i actually
sorry i don't know this year i actually
had a small typo here uh explainer right
over here
okay should be boss underscore explainer
okay so who wants to go ahead and note
that okay so
all right so my my apologies
all right so the idea then okay
uh kind of uh the
you know the core contribution right of
the shop library what it really does
that's unique
okay is it just gives you a very very
fast way to calculate uh the uh the
shaftly values of various types of
models so in this case
if we're looking at this right over here
okay where we passed an x underscore
boss right over here okay
all right
is basically um
it went ahead and then calculated the
sharply values for everything inside of
our training set
okay you might notice this actually
happened much more quickly than what we
did in kind of like our standard
standalone sample uh someone mentions
like if you have like test data
okay um or you know if you have out of
sample data things like that uh the idea
is you actually could go ahead um and
then still calculate uh shapley values
for them right because it's actually
very useful right to have you know out
of sample calculation of future
contributions
uh for uh for new samples
uh the only thing you'd actually need to
do that was a little bit different
okay is actually when you initiate the
explainer right over here uh you could
actually go ahead and then pass in uh
your data set here at this step
okay and so at this point i would go
ahead and then calculate the sharply
values there and then if you pass in the
new sample right over here like it's
like an individual sample from your test
set or something new that was coming in
live
okay uh it could basically then go ahead
and then calculate uh the shackley
contributions
based off the training set that you had
in here
all right so important point yeah you
actually can use shaq to kind of
calculate um
uh you know shaft values uh for
individual samples that are out of
sample
okay
but in any event okay uh really one of
the big contributions okay and then the
contribution right is the ability to
calculate sharply values um kind of
across a wide variety
of of different models and contexts
okay
it's the same thing here uh you base
value right over here 22.54 okay and so
then the idea then right if for each
individual sample if you add up uh the
shaft values
okay and then add them to the base value
that'll go ahead and then give you your
model prediction
okay
so this really is kind of like the
fundamental uh sort of uh you know
uh progression or uh you know technology
inside the shaft library is being able
to calculate these values very very
quickly
uh something else though typically does
quite well right now on top of that is
it gives you a number of different
graphing tools uh for being able to
visualize that
okay this is just kind of standard
matplotlib uh so for quite a few of
these charts you could probably just
recreate them on your own if you wanted
to
okay but we'll go ahead here
all right and just kind of take a look
at some of the base functionality okay
uh inside uh the actual library itself
okay
uh this is just the actual absolute the
absolute value average absolute value
excuse me of uh chat values of each of
the individual columns
this corresponds reasonably well to
something like feature importance that
you might be used to doing they'll
typically give you pretty similar
results
okay
but again something about shaft which is
very very nice right
is uh you actually have these sort of
like feature contributions both at a
global level right over here but you
also have them for all of your
individual samples
okay so in this particular case
all right what you're able to do here
and again if you wanted to you can kind
of like take your shop values and like
put them into your own graphing
solutions
uh if you wanted to uh this kind of a
nice way of doing it
um this is the more handy
is uh you can actually see the
distribution of your shop values of
reaching the individual columns all
right this kind of something where um
you know it kind of does what things
like uh feature importance or maybe to a
lesser extent uh something like partial
dependence i can't do nearly as well
okay
so in addition to kind of like global
averages
uh you can see how something uh like you
know future contributions are
distributed
okay across throughout your entire data
set
okay and can you see like some of these
tend to be bunched together uh others
tend to be a bit more spread out you
know sometimes it can be interesting uh
you know you might have like a male
female you know column or individual
groups
okay so if you kind of isolate uh the
individual impact you know the street
categories things like that
lots of times this kind of allows you uh
to kind of see visually how different
types of model contributions are bunched
together across features
okay and then we'll go through a few
more of the charts here
this right over here is literally uh
just kind of calculating um like shaft
values across different values of a
particular column
okay which you can see over here like
this
all right
and then also here
uh chat typically has a very very useful
facilities
uh for visualizing model contributions
at the level of a single prediction
uh which is often uh some of its most i
think and most important benefits so the
idea then is if you have
uh you know an individual prediction
that's out of sample something new
that's coming in
okay and you're using something like a
gbm or a neural net or things like that
you want to understand that kind of like
what's actually contributing at this
predicted value uh you can go ahead and
do that okay
uh
pretty much the two standard ways of
doing this
okay there's something called the force
plot
okay and it also has a kind of a zippy
waterfall chart as well okay same thing
where you start with the base
contribution and then you go ahead and
then add up the individual contributions
in each individual column and things
along those lines
okay and again um all of these charts
are basically just drawn from the actual
basic value
calculations
okay um
uh but
you know this is visually i think uh
pretty easy and kind of gives you pretty
good out of the box results
okay um same thing we're gonna answer a
few more questions uh towards the end of
class uh here which is actually coming
up pretty soon uh so we'll kind of take
note of
what's on people's minds and then go
from there
uh what i'd like for us to do now here
okay
all right is at least for a little bit
okay
uh let's take about 10 minutes or so
all right just so there's a little bit
of hands-on exercise
because i know here i it can be a long
time to listen to one person talk for a
while uh over here down here in the
notebook okay uh this is a small
exercise
so what we did here uh we loaded in a
new data set
all right and so essentially what this
kind of comes down to
all right is just being able to recreate
some of the charts that we had above
over here but for a separate data set
all right
and so um the starter code is right over
here right you have x and y and then you
go ahead and fit your model
so assuming you have it uh saved in
drive okay
i'll say let's take about five to ten
minutes
all right and just try recreating a few
of the different charts you're given a
prompt of some different questions right
over here
uh you know the three most important
features okay or how's interact kind of
like how does it change across the data
set
okay um and so on and so forth uh
basically all of these things
okay
could be answered
by pretty much recreating different
versions of these charts right over here
so this is a simple exercise uh lots of
times doing things on our own i know can
be a a bit more interesting and engaging
than just kind of listening to me here
for the full time here so let's take
um let's take about seven to eight
minutes everyone okay
and uh just kind of go ahead and just
kind of work through these uh as much or
as little as you'd like
and then at about 40 past the hour we'll
kind of come back here and then just
talk about a few more remaining details
and then go from there
beautiful okay all right
so again hopefully that's an example
maybe just to kind of take a look right
kick the tires a little bit i know it's
not a huge amount of time uh but you
know it's it's something to kind of
reproduce from our own output
um so we have longer questions um
uh that i think are probably worth the
answering in different ways which are
really really helpful
uh so what i want to do here is i just
want to go over a few of the remaining
points uh regarding your shop and how it
can be used and then we'll see if we can
take out the last 10 or so minutes
um that uh to kind of go over everything
so real quickly here um for all of the
examples that i'm going to be doing
uh you can go ahead and then run
uh the corresponding code snippets over
here
okay uh to go ahead and follow along so
for example here
uh the first thing we're going to talk
about now are interaction values
okay and that shaft can go ahead and
then calculate for you again this is a
big thing right because we keep pressure
like multi collinearity of course too if
you're using cheap base models you know
uh tree based models have the um
you know benefit of actually capturing
you know pretty elaborate sets of
combinations
between different sorts of features
things on those lines all right so the
basic idea here
okay um in addition to kind of
calculating uh you know the separate
shot values right for each individual
column
um you can also calculate a shaft value
that actually takes uh the overall shaft
value for a particular sample
okay and it actually deconstructs it
into the independent effect to that
column
and then the contributing effect uh from
every single subsequent column inside
your data set
all right and so basically uh the way
that would work
okay it's again it's computationally
pretty intensive it can take a little
bit of time uh to go ahead and run
all right but the basic idea here
is in addition to being able to kind of
calculate the shaft value of the shaft
with sampling value for a particular
column right by holding one constant
sort of like you know ascending the
other one looking at the other one
between the two samples
you can also then essentially what you
do then
is you do that
for two columns jointly okay and then
what you do then um is you take the main
effect and then you subtract out
uh the contribution from an individual
column to kind of get the contributing
factor uh for each individual feature
within your data set
as the idea is you can actually take the
idea of a sharply sampling value and
have kind of like the unexplained
sharply effect that just kind of for
that particular column and then all the
individual contributions from everything
else inside your data set
um so if you're looking for kind of like
how things might coincide with one
another or concurrence or things like
that
um you know you actually have those
capacities
okay and so the idea then
uh again uh what you get as a result
here is multi-dimensional so it can be a
little bit difficult to wrap your head
around
uh so when you actually are done
calculating interaction values uh this
data set is 506 by 13.
okay uh when you're done here you're
actually going to have a 506 by 13 by 13
data set
okay so meaning
when it comes to interaction values
okay
uh each row
each sample is going to have its own 13
by 13 matrix of interaction values
okay and then if you wanted to you can
go ahead and then see that over here
okay
um i have some slides here which i think
break it down i think hopefully a bit
more clearly
all right
so the basic idea right uh when you're
done going ahead with shop you might
have something for a column in this case
boosting is 6.4
right but again the big thing is you
know different types of columns kind of
contribute right uh to kind of the
importance of a particular feature so
again um calculating the interaction
right it's again
kind of calculating the shaft value
jointly with each of the individual
columns
uh subtracting that out from the overall
shaft values that way you kind of have
the main effect and then the effect you
can attribute you know to each of the
you know individual columns cosigning
with it so then the idea then
uh what you can do then is for every
single shaft value for every single
sample you have the main value
which is actually just the contribution
of the main effects
uh added together with all the
individual effects from each of the
individual columns itself
okay and so effectively then
all right
when you actually have an interaction
value
all right if you actually look okay at
the matrix which in our case is 506 by
13 by 13. this is a simplified example
okay if you had a three column data set
okay and you're calculating the shaft
interaction values for them
okay um
the interaction values for a single
sample would look like this it'd be a
three by three matrix
okay uh the values going down the
diagonal
okay would sort of be the independent
effects okay for that particular column
okay across each row
all right these are the contributions uh
for every other column inside the data
set and then if you add these up
together that gives you the final shot
value for each column itself
okay
so you can deconstruct um shaft values
into various types of contributions from
different combinations of columns which
lots of times is fairly helpful
uh so an example output is something
like this
oops i think our size over here
okay
um so we looked at the boston data set
right
uh this if you actually model the
interaction okay between lstat
and then the room columns
okay the idea is basically what this
tells you
okay is that lower values of l stack
actually remove the impact of room
okay so that means as room gets larger
okay its contribution gets reduced by
lower values of lsat okay which you can
see over here
but on the right side over here right if
you to generate a shaft chart for room
and tax
okay the fact over here that the
contribution of room is basically
unchanged by tax
means that the impact of tax and then
the impact of room on your data set are
basically independent of one mother
okay looks like we have a few questions
about this
okay
all right so then the idea then so again
so once you're done uh you do have a
pretty robust way of kind of looking at
different types of interactions and how
one feature might influence another and
so on and so forth
okay
um real quick and again i would say if
you want to run through this uh we
actually have uh you run through the
notebook
um if you're doing um
a chat for classification uh the basic
code works about the same way
okay uh the only difference
all right uh the output that you're
going to get is log probability
okay which means uh when you're getting
the future contributions right over here
all right if you exponentiate these okay
it'll actually turn out output into raw
probability itself
okay um in the actual demo notebook uh
you have some code snippets that show
you both uh one way or the other
okay so i personally find it more uh
more intuitive more appealing right to
sort of say like the base prediction is
23 and this one added four this one
subtracted seven and things like that so
on and so forth
okay um
and again uh the example there is in the
shaft demo if you want to take a look at
it all right but it's kind of the base
output for classification
um another big thing here right a shaft
also kind of comes in
um with guard rails built in for
handling uh neural networks as well okay
so there's a pre-existing algorithm
called deep lift which is typically used
to kind of calculate relative importance
of things like words or pixels or things
like that to a deep learning model
um
again so chap basically co-opted that
and then use it to calculate sharply
values for it
and so the basic idea then okay
i'll be honest this part is a little bit
buggy it doesn't always work seamlessly
it depends a lot on what types of
versions of the libraries that you're
using
okay but if something like a natural
language model uh you can actually
decompose the contribution of individual
words for a particular sample
uh to see what they actually use to kind
of go and contribute to the final model
output and then you can also do
something for images
where you can basically clump together
groups of pixels together
to figure out how they might contribute
uh to a final predicted outcome from one
thing or the other okay
i would like to say this part right over
here is completely seamless um but in my
experience you typically do have a
little bit of friction uh getting it to
work uh but you do kind of have like a
built-in native support uh for different
types of neural networks
all right um so a few a few closing
thoughts here i think we're kind of
getting close to our time we have 10
minutes left obviously keep things open
for questions i know we have a few here
so let me go ahead
um so just a few more points here
i want to go ahead and bring up all
right so
interactions okay so a few points that's
kind of to point out here uh definitely
i know like if you look at different
presentations here in pi data
um you know the causal inference is
definitely mentioned quite a bit i
always think this is worth pointing out
um
shop
right allows you to perform pretty
elaborate uh model inference so what
types of patterns right were found in
your data and how are they attributed
right to different sorts of features
things along those lines uh it's not
quite causal inference all right with
causal inference you have to have some
kind of counter factual right
uh some kind of what-if scenario
something else would have happened and
so
if you have persistent correlations
inside your data like all throughout
your training data and something um in
your test set is genuinely different
right it'll tell you basically based off
what happened on your training data but
it's not quite the same thing it's just
kind of running like an actual
controlled experiment or things along
those lines a lot of times these two are
going to dovetail together pretty
closely
um but again i think it's usually a good
idea to distinguish uh between the two
uh model inference and causal inputs
lots of times they will be pretty
similar
but in my opinion they're not exactly
the same thing
okay uh other thing too is it's
important to think of shaft as basically
being two things
um it's core technology right is its
ability to kind of calculate uh shapley
values quickly and efficiently
okay and that's when you go ahead and
load in the model explainer
um it also kind of has graphing
utilities built on top of it okay
however though the graphing stuff that
it does is actually just different types
of matplotlib charts uh tacked on top of
of the actual shaft values that were
computed um so you wouldn't necessarily
have to do this and so i've actually
found on my own lots of times um if
something like this is being used in
applications or in dashboards or things
like that i typically just kind of take
the shop values and then pass them into
like another graphing library or things
on those lines
um so they're not exactly one of the
same
um and then something else i'm going to
point out um
if you look through the actual shaft
demo notebook
there are definitely a few extra lines
added to kind of point out where
something was a hack
uh so there is a little bit of headwinds
because sometimes you might have to do
things slightly differently depending on
what model that you're using
okay like i've noticed a shaft or
something like gradient boosting and
something for scikit-learn
doesn't always happen quite the same way
and then also as shaft as of now doesn't
actually support pi torch for neural
networks uh only tensorflow if you
actually download like a working version
and then clone the github repository and
then use one of their working branches i
believe they actually do have some
versions of it uh to support it now but
in terms of the official release uh it's
not there yet
okay but in any event um
definitely it seems to be a very very
useful tool uh definitely the last two
years has become extremely popular i
actually believe it's one of the most
trafficked github repositories now
um in an open source and ml and so uh
this happened in a pretty very fast time
uh some because uh you know it's the
hole that it fills is a pretty important
one um and it gives you a pretty good
toolbox uh for doing lots of things
so uh hopefully you guys will have uh
some additional uh you know motivation
and wherewithal to go ahead and do it
and a little bit of practice using it
and some background information
um that is all i have for today everyone
um here's a link to some additional just
helpful resources i will post them in
the slack channel afterwards
uh pretty much everything uh was more or
less uh kind of covered in various ways
uh throughout
um
you know throughout the the actual
exercise itself but just in terms of the
actual repo or some of the literature
that was used thrive at things along
those lines
um it's it's all there okay so let's
uh go through a few questions here
um one that stuck out okay a few people
have
okay is um you know how can a column
have large and small values at the same
time
that's not contradictory whatsoever
remember um so shaft values
are for specific values and specific
samples
okay and so the idea is right is for
every single sample what was the
contribution for that particular value
to a final prediction
may be kind of a useful analogy here is
if you had something like income and
then you're modeling that to kind of
determine life expectancy
uh you'd expect you know someone with
zero income
uh that number right would negatively
contribute
right to the final model prediction okay
but if someone you know that you're in
the top one percent of the top one
percent uh you know uh you'd expect that
number to possibly contribute
okay um
you know to the actual final predicted
value itself uh so assuming you have
something on a numeric scale there's no
reason you know smaller values you might
subtract from a predicted value and
larger values might add to a predicted
value or vice versa
okay
hello
just a reminder i know you are
controlling the watch okay so it's five
minutes now four minutes left okay okay
beautiful yep no i got it got it got it
okay yeah so another question uh that we
had here
is
uh so something like a scatter matrix or
interaction plots out of the box
yeah um so
i actually believe if you actually look
at the actual shaft demo notebook uh you
actually do have exactly that like a
scatter matrix for interactions so for
anyone who's used to maybe using things
like partial dependence
you can basically use strap interaction
values to accomplish something fairly
similar
and so literally it's called the
interaction plot
it's inside the notebook itself uh but
also again uh probably following up i
can post a link to it uh from the github
repo
um and then
also
yeah shop does have a
built-in uh capabilities to basically
look specifically for uh transformer
models itself so if you're using
transformers uh transformers for for nlp
um there's actually an aspect of the
deep looked algorithm which has been
built in the shaft that go ahead and
handle that
same thing probably in the slack channel
i can go ahead and then post up some
follow-ups for that um but it's it's
it's there
okay
um and then i think
i think we've kind of covered everything
most of the things here right yeah as i
said i mentioned before so with like
something like a categorical variable if
it was binary uh same thing you would
basically do um zero one
um you know and then just kind of
contrast that with all the different
kind of combinations the columns and the
permutations and then you'd have uh
shaft values it's actually fairly common
if you have a column you know like uh
you know yes no this binary you
typically will see the distribution of
shaft values kind of clustered between
the zero and one values
um returning uh time series i actually
don't think it has
a great coverage for true time series
models
okay
uh
you know obviously if you had like time
series data like time series features
you could just sort of look at the
impact of that
um but in terms of maybe looking at
something like uh like an lstm and like
a time series model or things like that
like the forecasting the individual
steps i don't think it would actually
give you great coverage for that
all right um
okay i think that's gonna take me here
pretty much i think we're about time to
to head out here
i'm i'm not sure if you answer already
this question but i think it was larissa
was asking something about imbalance
data sets so she was assuming that
before applying sha probably you need to
correct the imbalance in the dataset
right so she was asking for confirmation
yeah if you're talking about something
like scaling or standardization or
things like that
uh really that shouldn't be necessary uh
but if you're talking about like
literally something that just so you
know like uh sort of unduly influences
it like in a way that's fairly noisy
yeah you probably would want to remove
it
i think it's in the way that you have a
minority class and a minority class when
you want to classify something for
instance like a suspicious spam filter
or whatever you will always have a
minority class with a lot of samples and
very few samples of the bad guys so that
that's why
when you have this imbalance
how do you need to correct that before
applying shot
uh no in that particular case no you
wouldn't really that wouldn't really be
an issue it is if you just sampled it
enough you would eventually get it would
you basically um just
you could eventually sort of like you
actually look at chat values for each of
the individual classes is basically the
way it would work and so therefore it's
like not just like a single like binary
example but for each individual one you
would take them and then sort of permute
the different values so even if you had
something that did not happen very very
like it's only one percent or a half
percent of the time things like that it
would actually go into the look
specifically for that particular outcome
hold that constant and then go through
the different permutations so therefore
you get the interaction of x so there
shouldn't be any sort of additional
special treatment you have to do on top
of it
outside of like what you might just use
to kind of get like the best model that
you could perfect okay thank you very
much so this session has uh finished
and thanks to all the participants
and also special thanks to our speaker
jonathan for for the great workshop and
for being here and part of the pi data
global 2021